[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire le 25
novembre se déroulait la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes lancé en
2018 le violent omètre permet de
sensibiliser les jeunes femmes aux
violences conjugales à travers un outil
simple comme nous l'expliquera notre
partenaire wo TV dans le Pas de Calais
auent sur le circuit Bugatti celui des
24 heur du M des enfants hospitalisés
ont eu droit à un tour de piste aux
étoiles pour leur plus grand bonheur
comme l' constaté vous le verrez en
image LM tvart sur place les cabanes
chanqué du bassin d'Arcachon sont aussi
célèbres que la dune du pil mais le
temps a eu raison de leur résistance aux
éléments marins il a fallu réunir les
fonds nécessaires à la reconstruction de
la cabane numéro 3 TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest nous emmènera faire un
point sur les travaux qui viennent tout
juste de
commencer enfin nous irons retrouver
avec via ATV le groupe cassave qui
entame une tournée mondiale en hommage à
l'emblématique Jacob devarieux emporté
par le covid-19 à l'été 2021 des images
tout à l'heure mais commençons tout
d'abord ce journal avec comme chaque
année la Banque alimentaire qui a
effectué sa collecte partout en France
et particulièrement dans 190 points de
collecte des bouches du rô au total 4500
personnes ont été mobilisées pendant 3
jours pour collecter un maximum de denré
avec au final un bilan équivalent à
celui de l'an passé écoutez Joseph
araquel le président de la Banque
alimentaire des bouches du rô on est aux
environs de 300 tonnes de marchandises
récoltées donc euh une générosité qui
s'est exprimée avec une forte
mobilisation des bénévoles la précarité
touche de plus en plus de monde c'est un
succès euh essentiel pas de nos
campagnes mais pour notre existence
parce que sans les pouvoirs publics on
pourrait pas exister c'est-à-dire ce
sont des financeurs hein et on a besoin
d'eux ce sont des institutions qui tel
que part incarne la République cette
république qui prend en charge des les
plus fragiles la précarité j'ai connu
puisque je suis d'une famille modeste
sans ces acteurs que sont les bénévoles
rien n'est possible c'est vraiment des
des gens qu'il faut remercier parce que
ils se mobilisent ils donnent de leur
temps bien souvent ce sont des gens
modestes qui qui viennent donner leur
temps il y a quelques jours se déroulait
la journée internationale de lutte
contre les violences faites au femme et
le plus difficile restant toujours de
libérer la parole des victimes dans
cette boulangerie du pas de calé quand
on achète sa baguette le papier
d'emballage a changé et désormais il
comprend un
violentomètre une sorte de thermomètre
de la violence pour beaucoup de femmes
le sujet reste complètement tabou c'est
ce qu'à constaté notre partenaire OTV à
betune
regardez préparer une baguette un geste
presque anodin pour ce commerçant
d'abville presque car depuis peu un
nouvel affichage s'est invité sur ses
étuies à baguettes un violentomètre
sorte d'échelle gradué des violences que
peuvent subir les femmes au sein de leur
couple on a effectivement des des
phrases qui peuvent paraître banales
rabaissent vos opinions et vos projet ça
va permettre à cette personne en
regardant le niveau de violence qu'elle
subit ou pas de se dire est-ce que je
suis aujourd'hui une personne violentée
objectif de l'initiative lever le voile
sur des violences parfois insoupçonné à
l'arrière de l'étuie figurent les
numéros d'urgence comme le 3919 pour
permettre aux femmes victimes de
violence de trouver une issue face à des
situations dangereuses bah c'est pas mal
il y a peut-être des gens qui vont qui
vont réagir à ce papier quoi plus on va
en parler plus on évitera sans doute les
drames qu'il y a trop dans notre société
est-ce que les les femmes vont vont dire
leur violence c'est toujours un peu
caché tout ça pour la 3è année de
l'opération la municipalité
d'abevilleille a imprimé 20000 étuis à
baguettes et misé sur 17 boulangeries
des lieux de passage pour de nombreux
habitants
la ville comporte grosso modo 23 24000
habitants ça nous permet de de toucher
un public très large tous les jours vous
achetez du pain vous achetez une
baguette ça va plus vite vous prenez le
sachet de de baguette et vous voyez
derrière vous lisez obligatoirement bien
bien évidemment parce que on le fait
qu'une fois par an donc ça interpelle
davantage les les les personnes les
femmes les enfants aussi des jeunes ados
qui peuvent être concernés si l'outil de
prévention pourrait permettre de libérer
la parole des femmes les chiffres sont
éloquents selon le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
en France 80 % des plaintes déposées
pour des faits de violence conjugale
sont classés sans
suite accompagner les futures mamans
dans leur grossesse par des cours de
danse l'idée fait son chemin comme nous
allons le voir dans l'Aube où trois
femmes enceintes inauguré ce premier
cours de danse périnatal des vertus
tonifiantes pour le corps et un moment
privilégié pour ses futures MAM notre
partenaire Canal 32 a rencontré Amandine
Jean professeur de danse et elle aussi
maman
elles ont 7 8 et même 9 mois de
grossesse et ont pris rendez-vous pour
un cours de danse un peu particulier ce
samedi après-midi dans cette salle de
Saint-André les vergers le créneau est
réservé à la danse périnatale un projet
qui tenait à cœur à Amandine Jan
professeur de danse c'est une idée qui
trottait dans ma tête depuis la
naissance de ma fille mon 2è enfant en
2021 en fait moi j'ai fait du yoga
prénatal post-natal et d'avoir une
activité tout le long de ma grossesse ça
m'a vraiment vraiment aidé à récupérer
après on soulève le genou d'abord les
étirements suivent les mouvements de
balancier au son de la musique
thahïtienne de quoi tonifier les muscles
certaines parties du corps comme le
périné sont particulièrement sollicité
ça permet bah d'avoir un temps pour
respirer pour s'étirer pour relâcher les
tensions mais aussi pour tonifier tout
le corps pour activer la circulation
sanguine parce que c'est très important
quand on est enceinte Naomi attend son
deè enfant après 7 mois de grossesse
chaque mouvement est exigeant les
grosses difficultés c'est qu'on a le
poids de bébé dans notre corps on n'est
pas tout seul donc donc ça pèse un peu
et puis c'est pour ça que des fois on on
préfère s'asseoir pour se reposer un peu
et puis après on repart à la fin de la
séance c'est un peu fatigué mais surtout
détendu que les futures mamans rentrent
chez elles ça nous permet de nous nous
détendre de pas forcément penser à la
fin de la grossesse et vraiment de
passer un moment un petit peu hors du
temps se recentrer sur sur nous et sur
le bébé objectif pour Amandine et
l'association précieuse et compagnie
faire connaître la pratique et ses
bienfaits une séance sera ouverte chaque
mois la première ministre Elisabeth
borne a présenté en début de semaine son
plan interministériel de lutte contre
les violences faites aux enfants le
nouveau plan contre les violences qui
succède au plan 2020-2022 comprend une
vingtaine de mesures avec une attention
particulière au recueil de la parole de
l'enfant le CHU de Saint-Étienne vient
d'ailleurs d'ouvrir une unité
spécialement dédiée l'unité d'accueil
enfants en danger propose des locaux
sécurisants pour les enfants avec une
équipe formé à l'accompagnement de ces
mineurs victimes c'est un reportage de
Nathan Vachet pour TL7 dans la Loire
répondre à un besoin urgent quand un
enfant est victime de violence qu'elle
soit volontaire ou non dans un cadre
chaleureux l'objectif de l'apè est
d'abord de comprendre l'enfants avec des
professionnels on accompagne l'enfant
avec des professionnels formés des
professionnels qui sont qui qu'il savent
qui savent de quoi sont fait ce type de
de prise en charge des psychologues bien
entendu des médecins pour lesquels qui
ont une appétence particulière pour ce
sujet et puis une équipe soignante
l'uaped est un lieu unique dédié à une
prise en charge globale et surtout plus
ridisciplinaire outre les soins des
lieux comme une salle d'audience sont
dédiés au servicees juridique ainsi
qu'aux policiers et au gendarmes il faut
avoir un endroit où l'accompagnement du
mineur victime puisse être immédiatement
engagé parce qu'on peut pas avoir un
enfant qu'on détecte comme étant victime
de violence et pour lequel la prise en
charge médico-psychologique se ferait
dans un temps très très éloigné donc
l'APED c'est un outil qui permet de
regrouper les compétences au même
endroit y compris les compétences des
enquêteurs et donc de mieux prendre en
compte ces situations installé au sein
du pôle femme mère couple enfant au CHU
de l'hôpital Nord luapè de la Loire a
bénéficié de 466000 € versé dans le
cadre d'une convention signée pour 3 ans
avec l'ARS financeur de ce projet voilà
et le gouvernement a par ailleurs
annoncé le renforcement des équipes du
numéro national alerte enfant en danger
le 119 et je vous rappelle que ce numéro
est dédié à la prévention et à la
protection des enfants en danger ou en
risque de l'être tout à fait autre chose
on se rend sur le circuit Bugatti du man
à un mois de Noël se déroulait la 5e
piste aux étoiles un événement caritatif
au profit des enfants hospitalisés toute
une journée des pilotes ont proposé des
baptêmes pour faire découvrir aux jeunes
le monde du sport automobile au volant
de bolide de course un moment de joie
partagé par Antony piton pour LMTV
[Musique]
Sart super Nick la vache cétait trop
bien Dorian vient de réaliser un rêve
tourner sur le circuit du M à plus de
300 km he ah ben c'était incroyable
vraiment d'avoir une voiture comme ça
incroyable vraiment j'étais au paradis
hein c'est le même sourire qu'on trouve
sur les visages de 11 adolescents tous
sont hospitalisés au centre de l'Arche
et vont enchaîner les accélérations à
bord de voitures de course là là dans la
Porsche vraiment j'ai senti j'ai tout
senti trop de sensation la vitesse
j'adore ça donc c'est super cool de
faire
ça des applaudissement car la veille la
piste aux étoiles a permis de collecter
62000 € pour le centre de la l'événement
caritatif est organisé par le premier
pilote quadr amputé à avoir participé au
24 he du M de faire partager des moments
de piste avec les pilotes et tout ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui tient à
cœur aux enfants et qui me tient à cœur
également parce que parce que il faut en
profiter on a la chance de pouvoir leur
offrir ça et ça ça les sort de ce milieu
hospitalier qui est pas toujours très
drôle des souvenirs plein la tête pour
ces adolescents qui ont pu toucher du
Doig le rêve des 24 heur
voilà et au moment où débute la COP 28 à
Dubaï de nombreuses initiatives sont
prises localement en France comme ici
près d'Any où les enfants vous allez le
voir de plusieurs écoles ont planté 250
arbres pour préserver la diversité un
reportage de Fanny savar pour H
Mont-Blanc
regardez des pommiers des poiriers des
pruniers et même des péchés au total ce
sont 250 arbres qui ont été plantés sur
les terrains dépendants du château de
Menton par des enfants des écoles
alentours faire pour une plantation
d'arbres
pour essayer d'aider la nature à se
renouveler après des ateliers en classe
sur la nature les élèves de 10 écoles
d'Any et des aravies mettent désormais
la main à la patte un grand bol d'air
pour ces jardiniers en herbes qui ont
bien compris le processus de plantation
on positionne le tuteur à 10 10 cm de
l'arbre vers le
nord après l'arbre il faut le tremper
dans une
un mélange de d'argile etau cette
journée a été coorganisée par
l'association water family engagée dans
la sensibilisation à la préservation de
la nature présente sur tout le
territoire national elle développe des
programmes pédagogiques pour les
scolaires et sensibilise chaque année
plus de 40000 jeunes aux enjeux de la
biodiversité ce qui est génial avec tous
ces arbres qui sont plantés aujourd'hui
c'est que non seulement ils vont
contribuer à l'activité de maréchage
naturelle mais en plus c'est un lieu de
pédagogie qui va recevoir d'autres
enfants qui va recevoir des adultes en
formation sur l'agroforesterie près de
80 % de ce nouveau verger sera garni de
pommiers aux variétés locales comme la
belle de boscope ou la grande Alexandre
de Savoie ici les arbres fruitiers ne
sont pas plantés au hasard le tracé est
le fruit d'une longue réflexion c'est la
naissance d'un verger qui va devenir une
forêt jardin c'estàdire qu'on va
cultiver en plein champ des légumes
autour de lign d'arbres fruitiers qu'on
est en train de planter ici sur sur
cette sur cette face face face au lac et
au Château de menton avec une une
problématique ou un enjeu de de gestion
de l'eau puisqu'on a pas mal de sources
et on a pas mal de ruissellement sur ce
terrain là donc la présence des arbres
fruitiers va permettre de de canaliser
de faire de ce qu'on appelle de l'eau
verte c'estàd capter de l'eau suite à la
première odyssée des arbres les enfants
pourront revenir avec leurs parents pour
découvrir l'évolution du verger d'autres
plantations scolaires sont prévues pour
les qu prochains sur tout le territoire
national il y a plus de de semaines
plusieurs tempêtes touchai
successivement la Bretagne et laissé de
nombreux dégâts derrière elle dans le
morbillan les parcsostréicoles ont été
particulièrement touchés et ce n'est
qu'à l'occasion d'une grande marée cette
semaine que certains professionnels ont
pu constater les vrais dégâts un
reportage de Marie sébir pour
TBO des tables renversé des poches
arrachées le parc aostréicle de Michel
et Antoine est métamorphosé à après les
tempêtes successives l'urgence du moment
désensabler les huîtres on aoulevé not
table qui était à l'envers avec les
poches dessous tout ce qui était tout ce
qui était élastique et poche arraché on
a tout remis sur les tables histoire
qu'elle respire et qu'elle se nettoie le
temps de la marée et si on les retour
pas maintenant vont mourir donc là on
essay de retourner le maximum mais avec
le Veng ça va bien continuer tomber bah
ouais c'est ça encore estce qu'on a pas
fait ça pour rien aujourd'hui on sait
pas les deux austriculteurs estiment
qu'au moins 3000 poches de leur parc ont
été touché Mo mais après faut savoir ce
que ce qui reste on sa pas on sera pas
ça avant Mme le début deannée perdu on a
perdu
50% moi je pense qu'on a perdu entre 10
et 15 s ah oui soit la moitié de leur
production le coût des dégâts reste
encore difficile à estimer mais pour les
austriculteurs la course contre la
montre est engagée à quelques semaines
des fêtes de fin d'année il faut sauver
les hres
rescapé voilà les Jeux olympiques de
Paris approchent ils sont pour en fin
juillet il est donc temps de constituer
les équipes sportives bien sûr mais
aussi celles qui permettront le bon
déroulement de cet événement mondial à
Saint-Quentin en yeline se déroulait
récemment un job dating
XXL afin de pourvoir de nombreuses
offres d'emploi notamment dans la
restauration collective comme l'a
constaté Clara de Frutos pour
tv78 on recherche 6000 postes pour
l'ensemble des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dans le domaine de la
restauration on rencontre des personnes
qui recherchent on leur explique
justement ce que l'on recherche et on
recueille leur CV de manière
électronique puisqu'on a une équipe de
recrutement dédié qui va les recontacter
ensuite pour recruter restons dans les
Jeux Olympiques des jeux qui proposent
de nombreuses épreuves nautique pour
lesquels il est nécessaire d'aménager
des pontons spécifiques notamment sur
les quais de la scinene c'est une
entreprise de saintmalot qui a été
choisi Claudia caratori l'a rencontré
pour TVR à reen
regardz
ces modules seront dans quelques jours
sur les quai de scène au total 300 m
linéaires de ponton doivent être
installés au village olympique des gios
de Paris avant le 15 décembre alors là
il y a si modules qui viennent de partir
on vient réétaler si plus si autres et
puis la dernière étape cette semaine on
va commencer le montage de la terrasse
Finau qui sont sur des ouvrages un petit
peu plus grands que que les modules
encore B pour répondre à l'appel d'offre
cette entreprise spécialisée en ouvrage
bois et métal a dû acheter de nouvelle
machine comme ici ce plasma haute
définition pour ce marché de 3,8 million
d'euros ecmb a investi 300000 € mais
Christophe Legavre a dû aussi recruter
et passer une partie de ses équipes en
de8 là le le fait de savoir que c'est
les Goos c'est vrai que ça nous met un
petit coup de pression mais ça c'est de
la bonne pression c'est et puis oui
c'est une fierté parce qu'on pourra
aller voir après les Jos comment comment
c'est est-ce que tu peux nous montrer
s'il te plaît le le projet des j le
projet a donné aussi du fil à retordre
au dessinateurs des plans qui a dû
s'adapter au terrain très arboré il y a
eu plusieurs relevés géomètres parce
qu'il y avait l'implantation des armes
mais ensuite on s'aperçut que les arbres
ils ont des racines et qui sortent de
terre donc il faut fallait pas y toucher
non plus et après la la difficulté
d'amener nos éléments autour des arbres
et entre les arbres moi ce que j'aime
avant tout c'est travailler en équipe
voilà donc seul on va plus vite mais à
plusieurs on va plus loin et là
symboliser ça par un chantier des gios
c'est travail un bon travail d'équipe
d'équipe et l'aventure va continuer
puisque Christophe Legavre vient de
l'apprendre il sera l'un des porteurs de
flammes lors des Joos
2024 nous constatons souvent l'artisan
d'art disparaît peu à peu et ces
porteurs de savoir de haute qualité sont
trop souvent isolé installé à limoge
l'atelier comme une fabrique c'est son
nom regroupe quatre artisans artistes
une émailleuse sur métal une tapissière
d'ameublement un restaurateur de meubles
et un artiste plasticien un lieu partagé
qui au-delà de la discussion conviviale
autour d'un café permet de partager des
expériences pour cet alimoge alain dreuo
a rencontré un artiste plasticien
regardez ici on a quatre résidents du
coup aujourd'hui donc une tapissière
d'ameublement une éméilleuse sur métal
un artiste plasticien et un restaurateur
de meuble c'est un lieu de travail c'est
un lieu de de vie au quotidien c'est une
partage de charge donc un espace de
travail à peu près autour de 150 €
charge comprise c'est vrai que le côté
bah pouvoir se retrouver partager
ensemble on a des métiers qui sont
différents mais au final c'est ça
apporte énormément de pouvoir se
retrouver
d'échanger les cabanes chanqué de La
Teste de bûche sont connues dans le
monde entier installé sur les rives du
bassin d'Arcachon elles subissent les
assauts du temps et nécessitent un
entretien régulier un entretien qui
coûte très cher et qui nécessite une
organisation complexe car les
entreprises en charge de la
déconstruction et la reconstruction ont
une contrainte de taille attendre la
Maré basse pour pouvoir travailler au
sec au sud de l'île aux oiseaux un
reportage de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion
que le maire de La Teste de bûche
Patrick Dav a entamé lui-même les
travaux de démolition de la cabane Chan
numéro 3 ce lundi matin vous êtes
vraiment ému quand même ouis oui oui
beaucoup c'est pour ça que je je suis en
train de si je suis en train de me
défouler pour pour pour évacuer
l'émotion ouis c'est ça c'est votre
votre manière évacuer exactement moi je
vous laisse évacuer alors allez voyez je
suis en train deesser là un geste
symbolique pour marquer le coup du début
de ce chantier confié à l'architecte
local Jean du brousse c'est lui qui en
2008 a mené les travaux de
reconstruction de la voisine de la
cabane chanqué numéro 3 la blanche
numéro 53 on va tout déconstru on va
tout enlever on va remettre le le site à
nu on va arracher le les fondations
béton qui actuellement on va tout tout
enlever le sable va revenir va revenir
recouvrir l'emplacement de la cabane et
là-dessus on va repartir à des fondation
neuve et une cabane entièrement
neuve la cabane Chan numéro 3 va être
reconstruite à l'identique avec
notamment du bois récupéré dans la forêt
usagère de l'atteste suite aux incendies
de l'été 2022 c'est remarquable parce
que oui parce qu'on a pas on n pas
beaucoup de l'occasion de construire en
milieu maritime et au milieu au milieu
de au milieu de de l'Est quoi c'est très
rare de construire dans ces conditions
là coût total des travaux 1 million
d'euros il devrait prendre fin en mai
2024 si les premiers canons à neige ont
été installés il y a 60 ans dans
lesvuges il n'est toujours pas
nécessaire d'y avoir recours à un mois
de Noël une dizaine de centimètres de
neige a suffit pour lancer la saison de
la glisse les équipes de VUG TV n'ont
pas pu résister regardez ces
images
une dizaine de centimètres de neige
fraîche aura suffi ces habitants de la
Plaine des vuges avaient décidé de
passer le weekend à la montagne on vient
souvent en fait ma grand-mère est de est
du coin et donc on est chez dans son
chalet et au sein de ce petit groupe la
neige était une première pour une amie
italienne oui pour la première fois de
toute ma vie depuis toute ma vie ouiz
jamais vu la neige bon non il n a pasah
en Italie il y a dans les Alpes mais pas
pas à nale
non tombé ces dernières semaines dans
les vauges mais cette fois l'épaisseur
du mentoné jeu était suffisante pour une
balade en raquette mainant on va aller
faire un décrassage c'està dire marcher
un petit peu tester les raquettes les
équipements en vu des prochaines neiges
ben c'est un super beau temps très
surprenant une couche de neige le début
de l'hiver super et après l'effort bien
sûr le réconfort dans une des rares
auberges qui ouvre l'hiver sur la route
des crêtes en cuisine Sam mijotte les
professionnels sont confiants pour la
suite on commence à avoir des
réservations et puis pas mal pour le
mois de janvier février mars et même
encore plus loin donc donc c'est bien
des plages chaleureux qui enrichiront
les souvenirs de ces touristes belges on
est venu en mai l' passé au refuge des
trois fours aussi donc au même endroit
il faisait un peu meilleur d'ailleurs la
route des crêtes elle est désormais
fermée à la circulation jusqu'au
printemps Jean-Paul Evin est un amoureux
de Paris le chocolatier parisien signe
un nouveau calendrier de l'avant pour
202 3 des compositions originales de
chocolat noir ou au lait pour les
gourmands et cette année le meilleur
ouvrier de France a choisi l'Opéra
Garnier emblème de la capitale Mélanie
fort l'a rencontré dans son atelier pour
20 minutes TV nos partenaires regardez
cette année on a fait le la thématique
du du palaisgarnier vous avez 24
propositions chocolaté différentes à peu
près 50 % de noir 50 % de lait
essentiellement des bonbons de chocolat
soit fait avec du géant Dujat soit des
pralinés il y a aussi des
il peut y avoir aussi des des mini
tablettes des petites choses comme ça
des amandes lait caramel fleur de sel ça
es sont très recherché cassav est de
retour pour une tournée internationale
en hommage à l'un de ses principaux
membres fondateur Jacob devarieux décédé
en 2021 des suites du covid-19 pour leur
premier concert à domicile depuis 4 ans
plus de 7000 personnes étaient au
rendez-vous en Martinique pour via TV
Sandrine Claude nous emmène
pour terminer ce journal
[Musique]
regardez plus qu'un hommage une
véritable déclaration d'amour à l'un des
leurs parti trop
[Musique]
tôt sur scène les membres de cassf
interprètent un large répertoire dédié à
Jacob Desvarieux un peu plus de 2 ans
après la disparition de l'un des piliers
du groupe les morceaux légendaires sur
lesquels il faisait vibrer le public
retonti de
nouveau avec un répertoire aussi riche
que l' sélectionner les morceaux de ce
grand concert hommage n'a pas été chose
aisée on avait décidé au départ de ne
faire que des titres de Jacob sauf que
si vous
présentez un spectacle avec que les
titres que tout le monde connaît ça n'a
pas grand intérêt fallait trouver les
titres aussi qui s'intègr au spectacle
que les gens connaissent moins connaisse
pas du tout ce que je ressens c'est de
voir le peuple qui répond à à l'hommage
à Jacob ça c'est extraordinaire Jacob
n'est pas mort pour moi non ça pour moi
il est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là on pouvait sentir je veux dire la
communion on pouvait sentir les gens je
veux dire quand on fait un concert et
qu'on salue deux fois B les gens ils
commencent à partir et là il reste ils
étai avec nous et c'était comme si on
avait pas envie que ça s'arrête et
c'était c'est extrêmement
touchant mission réussie pour le groupe
cassave qui a rappelé s'il y en avait
besoin que la mémoire de Jacob
devvarieux demeur et que son héritage
musical traversera bien des
[Applaudissements]
générations avant de nous quitter je
vous signale la sortie de ce numéro
spécial du magazine Le Point un spécial
Strasbourg les équipes coordonnées par
Valérie per posent la question de la vie
à Strasbourg face aux petites villes qui
sont de plus en plus attractives et puis
dans ce numéro spécial vous trouverez
aussi l'interview de Jeane barcégan la
maèire écologiste de Strasbourg qui y
livre ses priorités pour sa ville et sa
vision politique voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand des
territoires au revoir à
[Musique]
tous